2019's escape room is a wild ride with a
bonkers ending
and you can say the same for its 2021
sequel tournament of champions
from mysterious planes to the meaning
behind those strange shipping containers
this is the ending of escape room
tournament of champions explained
at the end of 2019's escape room we
learn that the evil minos organization
behind the movie's killer game
chose each participant for their status
as a sole survivor
of various disasters as the game's
master at the end of the first movie put
it they wanted to
know if luck had anything to do with it
tournament of champions introduces a
host of new characters who like ben and
zoe
have done this dance before none are
particularly keen on repeating the
experience
soon enough we learn about the qualities
that got these characters sucked into
mino's
machinations in the first place rachel
can't feel physical pain
and likely face horrifying psychological
torture during her game
briana survived a game featuring notable
influences
nathan entered the game with fellow
priests to test his faith
by picking specific groups of people
minos wants to test hypotheses about
faith
pain fame empathy and survival they
don't care who gets hurt in the process
and if it makes them a hefty sum of
money all the better
while many things still aren't clear at
the end of 2019's escape room we can
say with certainty that zoe and ben
aren't still trapped in an escape room
when they leave the first game alive
but their victory is still short-lived
as we then see minos operatives planning
what seems to be their next game with
zoe and ben's intercepted flight
information
so while the two champions may be back
to their old lives that doesn't mean
minos isn't still watching them
and given the number of people involved
in the airplane testing at the first
film's close it's safe to say that minos
isn't exactly a small time operation
it's clear that minos has people in the
real world manipulating things from the
outside
whether they're directly involved in ben
and zoe's lives or placed on the
outskirts to watch and report back
furthermore minos is capable of both
hijacking a plane and a subway train
one private company can't do that
without some high level connections no
matter how evil they are
what's more since we don't see most of
the dead characters actually die
there's no telling which players might
have been mino's double agents from the
start
the players first suspect ben after all
could they have been right all along
or is someone else pulling the strings
the deaths of the first film seem pretty
cut and dry by the time that story draws
to a close
but in light of the events of tournament
of champions we have to question
everything
if amanda can survive hurtling into an
endless abyss who's to say that other
apparently deceased characters didn't
also cheat death
and which ones might have been involved
with minos from the jump
in tournament of champions we're led to
believe that everyone except zoe amanda
and ben bite the dust
but how true is that really as amanda
tells zoe if she didn't see the deaths
herself they didn't happen
since rachel checks out theo's
electrocuted body to determine he's
actually dead he's the likeliest actual
casualty
but the other deaths are murkier after
nathan saves rachel from quicksand he
sinks to his presumed death
but that's how we initially lose ben too
we later discover ben survived to serve
as leverage for zoe to follow minos's
bidding
it wouldn't be surprising if nathan
survived too then
that brings us to rachel and brianna we
watch as a monsoon of acid rain assaults
them
but the film quickly cuts to zoe
freaking out the steam and smoke make it
impossible
to tell what really happens to them
which could be another trick
as amanda says if you didn't see it it
didn't happen so are they really gone
what the heck is going on with amanda
she shows up out of the blue toward the
end of the movie
claiming minos forced her into designing
the game that zoe just played
that's an interesting sentiment for her
to express considering amanda doesn't
come close to beating the game in the
first film
as an evil organization minos doesn't
seem likely to applaud anything less
than first place
and amanda was one of the first few
casualties in the 2019 film
while it's reasonable to believe that
minos might force her into designing the
latest game
especially since the game appears to be
plan b it's just as likely that our
innocent amanda has been amino's plant
all along
while amanda has mentioned her daughter
we never actually see any flashback
clips with amanda and sonia
we do however see amanda's time as a
soldier alongside the other characters
flashback sequences in the first film
the culmination of events at the end of
the film feels way too easy as zoe knows
it's entirely possible that amanda isn't
who she says she is
for all we know her daughter sonja is a
total fabrication
invented to hoodwink zoe into
cooperation
a massive display of huge shipping
containers can be glimpsed when the
characters escape the creepy bedroom
they're labeled nyc bdrm bch
and bnk these letters seem likely to be
shorthand for new york city
bedroom beach and bank in shorts the
escape rooms minos throws the characters
into during the scow round
at the top of course is our lone subway
car we also see a painting of an eight
ball
hinting that the original escape rooms
might be in this underground bunker as
well
the games have to exist somewhere of
course but the scope of the subway car
and the nyc room is mind-boggling
zoe and ben appear to get on a real
subway platform and a real q train
as we see it dislodged at the beginning
of the movie that's a massive feat to
pull off
any new yorker can tell you that the mta
is a hot mess on a good day
but building hiding and or inserting an
extra track wouldn't exactly go
unnoticed
to say nothing of how minos lord the
other champions onto this particular car
without anyone else hopping on
the fact that minos pulls off the subway
heights of the century speaks to the
connections and tech they have at their
disposal
but it also tells us that reality isn't
always what it seems
the subway car is likely a mix of
reality and a few minos adjustments but
what about the police station
when zoe and ben are on their doomed
flight and zoe questions how easy it all
seems ben says
you really think the whole police
station was bull yes ben
yes we do if there really was a raid on
minos's extracurricular activities
the involved parties would be
hightailing it to a country without
extradition loss
not throwing together another deadly
escape room so it seems like everything
else that the news broadcasts about four
found bodies and the manhunt is
fabricated
that means a guy who steals zoe's bag
and compass at the beginning of the film
is amino's plant who lures zoe and ben
into the specific subway car that also
means his arrest is an illusion
given how massive the police station is
this conspiracy goes dramatically deep
a staggering number of people must be on
the mino's payroll
there are probably multiple cops pulling
the strings and hiding evidence amino
says behest
it's too big of an enterprise not to
have those kinds of connections in place
while killer planes are certainly scary
learning a trusted ally is in fact a
manipulative liar is even scarier
when someone talks to a therapist they
expose their vulnerabilities
to learn that their therapist is
destabilizing their concept of reality
would be devastating
someone with deep rooted btsd from being
trapped in a killer escape room would be
especially shaken by this
while it's not abundantly clear that
zoe's therapist is involved with minos
there are some pretty shady coincidences
surrounding her
first off there's a lighthouse painting
in the therapist's office which
foreshadows the beach escape room
then at the start of the film the
therapist encourages zoe to take the
trip to nyc with ben
that's not entirely damning on its own
part of a therapist's job is helping
patients work through trauma
to achieve some level of normalcy let's
call this an orange flag then
not quite a red flag but not green
either from there things get worse
minos originally plans on hoodwinking
ben and zoe with a hijacked flight
they move to plan b when zoey can't
bring herself to get on the plane
what's plan b oh just a commandeer
subway car and what's the title of the
book the therapist brandishes at zoey
while accusing her
of finding clues in everything it was
called free will how to stop the train
of negative thinking
that's a little too much of a
coincidence to not be a clue
it's difficult to say for sure what
exactly goes down in tournament of
champions
due to minos's love of deception and
digital trickery
the why however isn't so muddy the
escape room franchise might bear
similarities to horror titles like cube
and soar
but tournament of champions has a hunger
games vibe specifically the hunger games
catching fire just as that film forces
previous hunger games winners to do
battle
tournament of champions pits those who
have survived mino's escape room
against each other the motivation for
the games in both film series is simple
the wealthy view everyone who isn't part
of their high-class circle as
entertaining playthings and the hunger
games the bloodthirsty elite are the
denizens of the capital
in the escape room movies it's whoever's
paying for a front row seat to menos
deadly games
they say that money can't buy happiness
but apparently it can buy
gladiator-style death matches
through this the escape room series
critiques societal stratification
and the way wealth corrupts morality as
well as offering a glimpse of the
horrific things people can do with
technology
if they're so cruelly inclined our
customers are some of the most
powerful people in the world but every
year they demand more
among all of the perks privilege can buy
is anonymity
minos and all of its wealthy patrons are
able to remain unknown
they hide behind their technology
torturing kids for fun from an ivory
tower while everyone else gets their
hands dirty
in contrast zoe and ben don't have the
luxury of disappearing behind the dollar
sign
the escape room movies deeply explore
what it means to be a survivor
and the lens to which someone will go to
save themselves who will fight for
others the series asks and who will
simply save their own life
the premise of the first film hinges
entirely on survival
each and willing participants soul
survivor background tells me knows
something about who they are
whether it's jason killing his best
friend or ben drunkenly but
unintentionally killing his friends on a
car crash but something about zoe saving
ben
continues to peak minos interest while
the rest of the champions games seems to
have been one and done experiments
minos remains fixated on the concept of
the survivor
why else would they throw previous
survivors in one ring to duke it out yet
again
the rest of the survivors appear to be
cannon fudder as minos sight remains
fixed on zoe
and their desire for her to build them a
new game zoe continues to survive
despite the criminally low odds of
living through the game
this makes her the perfect person to
design a genuinely unbeatable escape
room sequence
but she'll never agree to it more so we
think
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you